Speaker 1: We've been covering the Anti-woke
movement being in shambles.
And we have another data point in this that
I want to show you right now.
A new Gallup study finds that same sex marriage
support is at an all time high, 71% in the
United States.
The highlights here are this figure matches
the highest recorded one in history, which
was last year.
Support is lowest among Republicans and weekly
churchgoers.
If you're a Republican, only a 49% chance
you support gay marriage.
If you go to church weekly, only a 41%.
Young adults and Democrats are the groups
most supportive of gay marriage.
If you look at the historical chart, this
goes back to 1996.
You see that in 1996 there was 27% support
for gay marriage.
And in other words, the belief that same sex
couples should be recognized under the law.
Just like opposite sex couples that has climbed
and climbed and climbed all the way up to
71%, 71%.
If you look at different groups, you find
that in terms of church attendance, the more
you go to church, the less likely you are
to support gay marriage.
Women, slightly more than men, support gay
marriage, but the numbers are very, very,
very close.
And then basically, from 50 years of age and
up, you're less likely to support gay marriage.
The group most likely to support gay marriage
is those 18 to 29.
If you went to college, are more likely to
support gay marriage than if you didn't.
Obviously, Democrats more likely than independents
and Republicans to support it.
Regionally, we see that the South has the
lowest support for gay marriage.
So what does this tell us?
This tells us tells us a number of different
things.
Number one, it tells us that the so-called
culture war that the right loves to say they're
prevailing in when it comes to so-called boys
and girls sports and woke ideology and drag
and all of these things.
The right is losing.
You can't find any empirical data that the
right is winning.
You ask about abortion.
Support for abortion being legal in most situations
is higher than ever during the Roe v Wade
era.
Today.
Today, support for gay marriage is higher
than ever.
You ask people, Do you think we've done enough,
not enough or the right amount when it comes
to making transpeople feel welcome in society?
The majority says we have either done the
right amount or not enough.
That's the and that's not the Anti-woke position.
I hate to break it to these folks.
So that's why the right is trying to steal
elections rather than win them.
They will likely ramp up their fascistic rhetoric
and it is in the data.
You need only look at all of this data.
We have to understand why for DeSantis and
Nikki Haley and Pence now seems to be doing
it.
The Anti-woke agenda is not going to win them
the presidency, that's for sure.
They need to first figure out how to defeat
Donald Trump.
I am very interested to see more as a curiosity
than anything else.
Whether Chris Christie, once he enters the
race, runs on Anti-woke.
My instinct is that he will not, but remains
to be seen.
And we're going to watch it very closely.